This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6MtEnglish
from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello and welcome to 6MtEnglish. I'm Alice.
And I'm Neil.
So Neil, did you sleep well last night?
Uh, yes thanks. Why do you ask?
Today we're talking about how much sleep we need.
Ah, I like a good 8 hours myself, 10 at the weekend. How about you?
Ah, 6 is enough for me.
But did you know this?
Humans sleep around 3 hours less than other primates like chimps,
who sleep for about 10 hours.
So you're a chimp, Neil.
At the weekends at least.
Are you ready for the quiz question?
Okay, I'll assume that means yes.
Right, what's another word for sleepwalking?
Is it A?
Narkolepsy B?
Restless legs syndrome?
Or C?
Somnum mullism?
I will go for B. Restless legs syndrome,
since there's a connection with the legs.
Well, we'll find out whether you're right or wrong later on in the show.
So what keeps you awake at night, Neil?
Not much, to be honest. I usually sleep like a log.
And that means very heavily indeed.
But sometimes my own snoring wakes me up,
and then I can find it hard to get back to sleep.
Snoring for those of you who don't know
means breathing in a noisy way
through your mouth or nose while you're asleep.
Like that. How about you, Alice?
Very good, yes. Well, that's quite ridiculous.
Anyway, for me, it's drinking too much coffee during the day.
It's a caffeine in the coffee,
a chemical that makes you feel more awake,
which can stop you from sleeping at night.
But there are so many things that can keep us awake these days.
Oh, yes. Radio TV, techie stuff, like 24-hour internet computers,
smartphones. I love my phone. It's never far from me.
Well, let's hear what Professor Jerome Seagal
from the University of California found when he studied the sleep habits
of three different hunter-gatherer communities
who have very little contact with modern society.
They don't have artificial light, electricity,
batteries, or any of the gadgets that we rely on today.
Their sleep was not that different from ours.
The range of sleep period was about 6.9 to 8.5 hours.
If you actually measure sleep in current populations
in the United States or in Europe,
they're definitely at the low end of what's been reported.
They certainly don't sleep a lot less than we do,
but they clearly don't sleep more.
Professor Jerome Seagal found that people in these communities
don't go to bed until several hours after sundown, just like us.
But one big difference is that very few of them suffer from insomnia,
which means having difficulty falling asleep and staying asleep.
Now, I don't have a problem with insomnia
and hunter-gatherers, people who live by hunting animals
and gathering plants to eat, don't either.
Probably because they take a lot of physical exercise during the day.
Yes, that's right.
Taking exercise is an important factor in sleeping soundly or well at night.
But these days, our minds can be so active that it becomes very difficult to fall asleep.
Let's listen to Professor Kevin Morgan from Loveborough University here in England,
talking about how cognitive behavioral therapy can be used to help people with insomnia.
If you have a train of thoughts which would otherwise keep you awake,
one way of dealing with this is to block those thoughts.
What I'd like you to do is repeat the word THE in your mind at irregular intervals.
What you'll find is that the mind space required to do this
blocks out almost everything else.
So, Professor Kevin Morgan suggests saying one word over and over again at irregular intervals,
irregular, and this context means not spaced out evenly.
Doing it can help to block out the thoughts that are stopping you from getting to sleep.
It sounds like a very simple solution.
Wonder if it works.
Hmm, there's one way to find out, Neil.
Try it yourself.
Hmm, I will.
Okay.
And cognitive behavioral therapy, by the way,
is a treatment for mental health problems that tries to change the way you think.
Well, I usually count sheep if I can't get to sleep.
Do you do that, Alice?
No, not usually, Neil.
Okay, I think it's time for the answer to our quiz question.
I asked, what's another word for sleep walking?
Is it A, narcolepsy, B, restless leg syndrome, or C, some nambulism?
And I said B, restless leg syndrome.
Hmm, sorry, Neil.
It's actually C, some nambulism.
The roots of this word come from Latin.
Somnus means sleep, and ambulare means walk.
Narcolepsy is a condition where you can't stop yourself from falling asleep,
especially during the day.
Narcolepsy.
Hmm, and restless leg syndrome is a condition that makes you desperate to move your legs around,
especially when you're sitting quietly while trying to get to sleep.
Get to sleep.
Now, Neil.
Well, wake up.
Oh, hello, Alice, sorry.
Hello.
Can we hear today's words again, please?
Ah, okay.
Sleep like a log.
Snoring.
Caffin.
Insomnia.
Hunter-gatherers.
Soundly.
Irregular.
Cognitive behavioural therapy.
Well, that just about brings us to the end of this edition of 6 Minute English.
We hope you've enjoyed this programme.
Please do join us again soon.
Bye.
Goodbye.